okay so we got the episode the storm and
boy it wasn't it's an interesting one
you got some good good development of
pretty much our main hero and our main
villain you go into the backstory of
both of a man at first it's funny cuz
I'm watching and thinking to myself but
why are they doing both at the same time
each one should have like their own
episode so they can really dive into it
but the way they tie these two together
the way they tie both stories together
is so beautifully done it's so nicely
done at first while I was watching it I
was saying oh this is way too repetitive
you know they're gathered around the
fire and they're telling the story and
then you cut to the fire nation they're
gathered around the fire telling a story
and when they're telling the stories
they actually both complement and off se
each other perfectly which is very smart
and very clever and even at the end when
you see the Avatar EES flying away looks
down acses Zuko and they just exchange
this look and to them it's like any
other look but now we know to us that
they had this very large thing in common
that they both very much live in a world
of their core is massive regret over a
mistake that they made and both have
gone to very different extremes one has
gone to the extreme of being so consumed
by a day runs away from it and the other
has gone to the extreme of being so
consumed by they let it run his life he
devotes everything he can to fix the
problem pretty much uh and that's two
very interesting sides of the coin but
it's still the same coin so I thought
this one was very nicely handled um yeah
and for those who don't know am i okay
you know but this is this this is the
one where um Aang tells his backstory
about when he was with the monks why he
left and that is what happened he left
he wasn't sent away it goes a little bit
to UM against or the dilemma of whether
or not this kid should have been told
and now why he
was told I think that's important to is
that they know something big is coming
and they know this will they know this
will probably damage him and this is not
the best thing for him as a person being
told that he's the avatar he's gonna
have this great big weight set up Atum
and all this responsibility but much
greater things are at risk all that many
other people's lives are at risk of
course the big dilemma is that is that
worth it is that you know it justified
and that's it's a good question um and
so these two sides of the monks are
differing on it one you know wants to
teach him but still wants him to be a
child he he wants it to be mentally
stable and mentally sound and balanced
out because if not you're taking pretty
much the most powerful person in the
world and you're gonna turn into a
madman possibly um and the other is
saying no we don't have time for this
the you know bad things are coming
there's this war that we can sense and
we have to speed this along you know we
have to take the risk that hey he may
miss out on some parts of childhood but
at least he'll we can do it well enough
they he'll save the world you know and
stop war so it's a good dilemma and then
you also have uh this great story with
the Zuko well first of all I love the
conflict I shouldn't say conflate well
what am I looking for um I love how much
they set up that the crew is not happy
with him um and again your turn these
foot soldiers into people and I really
like that uh that they don't like they
think he's too consumed with trying to
get his on her back and revenge and
stuff like that and they and they
doesn't care for the soldiers at all
which he even pretty much said right to
want the soldiers faces I don't care
about you at all all that's important is
my Redemption pretty much um and I get
both uh the hero and the villain are
trying to get Redemption um and when
they hear the story I also a bazooka and
how he challenged this general for
something he thought was not morally
right
and but he didn't realize through sort
of a loophole it's not fighting the
general sense it was in his father's
quarters or in the in the war room
whatever that was he has to fight his
father and that he's actually he thought
he was being honorable enough by not
fighting him he could not fight his
father and the father being obviously
very mean gruff you know bad person
pretty much you know he burns his face
and that's where he gets that scar and
banishes him and it's a pretty tough
backstory for both of them um you know
as and there you can see how each one
equals out the way they do I really like
how you know it's not like something bad
happens that's like really extreme but
the person takes it too well or vice
versa or something really kind of into
school what happens that person blows
out purport it you know both are really
justified you can see how these how
these two kids came into being the
people that they are it's not just hey
let's have a tragedy just to have a
tragedy their tragedy they are both very
much fueled by their bad stories and
again by telling them side by side it
with it was so smart um and I think the
other thing about the Fire Nation too is
that it's showing very much you know the
kind of world they live in and I you
know how harsh it is and cruel is it has
sort of you know this barbarian Nazi ish
kind of feel to it
um and you know and there's this one
character especially like you know when
I think the uncles watch awake gave a
watch he turns his head away he can't
see you know Zuko get punished um and
there's this one girl on the front I it
looks like they're gonna make her a
character I be it shocked did they
didn't cuz she's way too well-designed
there's too much detail on this girl but
she just has like this look like this
evil will smile when she's clenching her
fists and like do she looks like she's
13 or something like that she's already
a killem killem you know and it's just
interesting seeing how like you know
everyone's sort of in this realm or at
least in the higher-ups at least are
very much along these lines and how they
would sacrifice you know essentially the
young soldiers to save you know or use
them as a distraction to bring in the
other soldiers to attack there's it's it
gives a great background to where Zuko
is coming from and that actually
something that was very honorable
they see is very weak and again that
makes that very interesting villain and
as you start questioning well is he
gonna be totally bad or is he gonna be
good is he gonna serve find these it's
again be ruled by his devastation by his
dishonor is he going to be ruled by the
fact that what he did was probably
honorable to begin with him that he had
good morals and tensions and ethics that
didn't agree with the nation so all that
stuff is wonderful um I'm trying
anything else it was just a good humor
again in this way you get some good
jokes from from sake you got the this I
fear there Mary cover no no it's I can't
remember that the fisherman and I can
our visits wife or client or what I'm
sorry I'm forgetting but both of them
have a lot of really really good lines
um and for whatever reason what I really
take out of this episode is just the
look that that Aang and Zuko give each
others who goes even far away but it's
like they and it's not for very long
it's just for like maybe a second but
they they take the time to really focus
on these looks of you know just Zuko
with his anger and anger his sir
wide-eyed innocence but they both look
very just confused and lost they look
very lost and you could see there was
just a connection there whether they
realize there was a connection there or
not but you know we know there is so and
again I like when a show or a movie show
something that there is a connection
regardless whether or not the characters
know various or not and so when they do
turn and look at each other even if
they're not aware of it we can see why
these two are actually much more similar
than they realize so I I'm gonna enjoy
seeing where that goes my if I had again
um and it can only go one of two routes
of thing it can either go that uh Zuko
is gonna go Darth Vader and sort of turn
around and be you know and say hey this
is this is I should do what I
think is morally right and go against my
father's wishes I see in the credits the
father's voice by Mark Hamill I mean
obviously he's just gonna be like the
diehard douche hey you know just the
pure villain um so he's either going to
go against and say no father you're
wrong and and this is right and I got do
what I think is morally right at it and
break off or he's just gonna be so
consumed that he's gonna want to turn
that way but he can't because his father
is too strong a control on him and it's
gonna be fun regardless it it's gonna be
interesting to see how they do that or
maybe there's a third option I you know
it seems like it has to go one of those
options but be interesting it somehow
they found like an in-between or
something so um yeah uh a really great
one a good really good developing these
characters and um I can't wait to see
where the connection goes next so yeah
that's about it great episode see you
next one